hello and welcome back to New rockstars
I'm Jessica Clemens and if you haven't
seen Pixar's newest teaser for their
newest Academy award-winning piece
Elemental I'm here to talk about it with
you this makes Pixar's 27th movie to
date and takes place in a metropolitan
City where air water fire and Earth live
together yes and if you like avatar The
Last Airbender you'll love this movie
but this focuses on what could be a new
friendship of the two protagonists Wade
and Ember as we know this movie will
have us in pieces in the end because all
Pixar movies like to do is make us cry
I'm also very supportive of openly
crying in theaters and being emotional
plus I love Pixar who doesn't I have a
Toy Story tattoo it's my childhood it's
my adulthood it's it's my everything
hood and I'm excited and will be the
first person in line to see this sweet
sweet piece of Animation so let's get
into Peterson's Elemental play-by-play
style so we don't miss anything play the
clip
thank you
[Music]
welcome to Cinderella's castle with the
floating Red Lanterns in the water
foreshadowing I think so the classic
shooting star in Pixar Animation Studios
intro with our boy looking up to us just
to fade in the background of Darkness
leaving nothing but luck so to
illuminate the screen like a light at
the end of the tunnel and oh wait it is
a tunnel to be more specific it's a
Metro raft a retro raft it says retro
above which is like a playoff Metro so I
see what you did there count all the
puns that they make in this trailer
there's a little blue blob driver I
suspect it's water and the bars around
the side with the little life preservers
around the edges and the front resemble
most rescue ships it clearly is a boat
that marries a Subway with the carts
behind them Subway you know how it has
like the train of things behind it is it
called Subway cars
cars not carts like the Pixar
with the cars behind them leave all that
in we're welcome to element City and
from the looks of the subway boat and
the different colored lines of Transit
we can expect the city to resemble like
New York or Chicago you know those
bigger cities it's actually in an
interview with Hollywood Reporter where
Peter Stone said she Ember was born in
the city but she grew up in the fire
town the neighborhoods are sort of split
up in different ways and she knows that
the city was started by water so we can
expect to see a sort of bigger city and
outlying suburbs later also at first
seeing the lines of Transportation I
immediately went to the periodic table
of elements a l being aluminum h b and
hydrogen and there's no solid a so then
I deduce a might be aqua and that's the
blue line for the water towns but what
would age that's teal be and then what
would the AL that's purple B then I
suspected that maybe they're following
the type of chemical group that are like
uh actinide I can't pronounce any of
these so just put them below actinide
the transition metal but the colors from
the table of elements actually vary
there's no actual Standard Version so
I'd lean more towards the last one and
maybe it's just the chemical groupings
because I'm sure there's trams that
cater to more specific elements than
others keep an eye out on these details
specifically the colors and objects the
sign that says element City Embers
headphones are beautifully designed
flame retardant jacket and dress this
movie is called Elemental and you can
see they really paid close attention to
detail aluminum or metal has a different
texture than plastic light beams off
stainless steel differently than the
linoleum floors Pixar has always been
great at this but you sort of know the
texture and the feel by just looking at
it now let's watch some more
oh
the song playing is Helen Back by Baker
a song about meeting someone who has
never been there before to open your
world to something brand new Love and
curiosity who needs it I need it we
first see a tree rooted in a ball of
soil he has a rock for a nose he's a
little businessman but his little
business briefcase and a business bow
tie okay Jessica enough he's cute we get
it we see a small soil ball just barely
sprouting a flower in front of him
possibly indicating their ages
everything's so cute it's making me go
crazy all the different human-shaped
water people looking like Osmosis Jones
sitting in water tubs for extra added
Comfort I wish I had that on a subway
also the subway schedule behind them
looks like the periodic table of
elements but also if the colors possibly
represent the other neighborhoods or
cities like Peter mentioned in his
interview then red would probably be the
fire Town blue would probably be the
indication of water-based towns teal
possibly the air base locations and
brown would be Earth we'll have to stay
tuned for the orange locations but I'd
love to hear what your theories are
about the orange locations down below so
many little posters on this Subway like
the poster next to the schedule that
says share the sunlight photosynthesis
is for everyone which is is very true
the sign that says no gusting leaking
sprouting a Garden Salon like a hair
salon an H2O and don't miss out on
periodical news this is a chemical
reaction baby a movie revolved around
science maybe it's just because I'm on
camera so much but I'm gonna tell you it
feels good to look this good if you want
to feel that I'm feeling good because
I'm looking good feeling more you gotta
get geology I tell you guys this all the
time geology is a 14 time award-winning
personalized skin care company
recognized in men's health Esquire and
ask men grooming Awards with over 6 000
5 Star reviews and they've recently
expanded to offer products for pretty
much whatever you need yeah if you need
hair care like I know you do use
geology's co-wash specially formulated
cream cleanser that removes buildup and
cleanses the hair without the big lather
or harsh ingredients of typical shampoo
and for the rest of your shower routine
you can use their body washes free of
harsh ingredients smell great or
refillable refillable sign me up protect
your skin from environmental stressors
with vitamin c e feralic serum to keep
your skin looking young and healthy like
mine and then a bit of dermatologist
tested aluminum-free deodorant quite
honestly smells great and I need it I
smell like a goat right now for a
limited time geology is hooking our
audience up with an absolutely insane
offer if you use code new rock stars
they will give you an additional 70 off
their award-winning skin care trial set
70 off you can't even get that on Black
Friday this discount stacks on top of
their current sale prices and there's
also an additional bonus offer on one of
their brand new skin hair and body
products of your choice when you add it
to your trial what are you waiting for
with the holidays right around the
corner geology has you covered check out
their awesome gift sets featuring all
your favorite geology products to get
started just click the link in the
description I'm I know it's below it's
somewhere it's probably gonna show up
right here take a 30 second diagnostic
quiz and their team of the dermatologist
will design a personalized routine just
for you and ships directly to your door
so when they go knock knock they throw
it at you and then you run away and you
wash your face immediately because I
know y'all got some dirty faces stop
touching your face get geology now let's
get into it some more
[Music]
five days
[Music]
the subway cart is full of so many type
of elements we have Earthly people
sitting in soil or sand one that's
growing crystals out of their head one
with a baby potted plants cloud-like
people and tank tops floating to the
roof and one word what I hope is a
jersey for the team windbreakers because
you get it like a windbreaker jacket
this guy reading fertilizers compost and
the self by in a Grove you get it
there's puns there's a ton of puns in
this trailer you just need to count them
when sneezed on his hair grows and it's
adorable little water sprinklers for the
folks it looks great but you notice
there's no other fire folks around just
Ember and this guy gave her a dirty look
and this woman pulls her kid away from
her I think it's easy to deduce not many
folks maybe get along with the fire
elements I mean it's a water-based
Utopia that didn't take fire elements
into heart when they even made a bus
that floats on a river that sounds
dangerous also fire with a lot of things
just you know doesn't lead to the best
outcome so I think that storyline is
there of feeling like an outlier in a
place that you do belong you do belong
there look at this beautiful city Pine
the swirl filter clouds these could be
apartments homes for different base
elements or just stores catered to air
water and Earth but again clearly no
fiery ones let's go to the next part
sorry
I'm Wade I'm Amber
[Music]
oh my God and not me already crying so
Amber you get the fun like fire Embrace
is played by an actual old friend of
mine Leah Lewis and Wade you get it like
waiting in water sorry the puns just
keep coming is played by mama do athy if
you saw light year you might have seen
his little Cameo I love the title
sequence and how it resembles the
periodic table of elements how most
periodic tables are color-coded based
off Elemental groups I also like how it
moves like a subway map you know how the
Transit maps look where they'll go
whatever Direction I'm just completely
excited to see what this movie looks
like especially seeing that Peter's son
said this movie centers around family a
story that reflects him being married to
someone that's not Korean and the
culture clashes that come with it and
exploring fire and water as they're both
so different but what their chemistry
would look like as a story that's enough
for me to Sprint jump and land in the
best seat on opening night I can't wait
for this movie it will be great I
promise you'll love it I'll love it
let's see it together and look out for
our breakdown of it next year let me
know in the comments what you think
about the movie follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at Lulu underscore Clements
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
but before you go the first week of
December the break room of new rockstars
will be at La Comic-Con and you can see
us there on Sunday around 10 or 11 A.M
just look out for our socials come hang
out with us come say hi yell at me about
this movie okay get your tissues ready
I'll see you later
[Music]